bonjour moi je suis le même jour je suis
le maire de la ville
un député a une bonne mémoire même un
dimanche matin jean-michel fourgous
fraîchement élu président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reste un homme
politique qui aime parler de chiffres
d'argent public et d'économie un pays
qui perd près de 100 milliards par an et
les mesures qui vont renaît sous forme
si on les prend pas on c'est dur à
prendre des mesures fortes ou pas jean
michel fourgous applique en tout cas des
mesures politiques depuis 25 ans et son
premier mandat en 1993 le docteur en
psychologie et diplômé de l'institut
d'études politiques de paris créé la
surprise et ravie alors à la gauche la
11e circonscription des yvelines
à 10h15 la sentence tombe elancourt
ville depuis longtemps conquise à guy
malandain passe à droite
un symbole puisque jean michel fourgous
bas guy malandain de 43 voix trois ans
plus tard en 1996 jean michel fourgous
remporte cette fois ci les élections
municipales à elancourt face au parti
socialiste il sera réélu trois fois et
même dès le premier tour en 2008 et 2014
ses ambitions nationales elles
connaissent des coups d'arrêt successifs
avec plusieurs défaites en 1997 ou 2012
face au ministre socialiste benoît hamon
je tiens à rappeler quand même que
monsieur benoît hamon a bénéficié d'une
inégalité de traitement devant les
médias qui est hors norme
bon donc j'assume
le résultat je lui souhaite bon courage
et jeu et je félicite la gauche qui a
quand même gagné ce soir
considéré par ses opposants politiques
comme clivant jean michel fourgous et en
tout cas fidèle depuis 25 ans à son
parcours d'entrepreneur le développement
économique et le thème essentiel de son
discours politique mais je crois que la
meilleure chose c'est de retrouver à nos
jeunes qui sont quelque peu en
difficulté d'en retrouver un emploi
ce sont les meilleures conditions parce
que quand ils sont au travail mais ils
font pas le zouave dans la rue et je
crois que
je crois que c'est une de nos priorités
essentielles il faut revaloriser le
travail
faut arrêter le dévaloriser faut arrêter
de dire aux jeunes que il est normal de
se droguer lors qu'il faut penser à
moins travailler j'ai pendant ce temps
là vous dire les retraites sont pas
garantis la sécurité n'est plus garantie
de la protection sociale qu'est la
retraite n'est plus garantie reste sur
place que l'on soit attractif qu'on
arrête de déclarer cette guerre aux
entrepreneurs aux investisseurs comme on
le fait actuellement
il faut se réconcilier avec le monde de
l'entreprise sinon on va perdre une
grosse partie de nos emplois cette
passion pour le monde économique
s'explique en partie par sa scolarité
mauvais élève jean michel fourgous
quitte l'école à 16 ans avant d'y
retourner quelques années plus tard
fasciné alors par le développement de
l'informatique
le fait de parts de diplômes au début ça
vous a pas ça vous oblige ça rend
intelligent dont ces mêmes des pauvres
ou de ne pas n'est pas rare de diplômes
ça vous rend intelligent parce que
obligé de chercher des solutions sans
faire appel à la méthode qu'on vous
donne après dans des grandes écoles
donc j'ai commencé par là puis après mon
j'ai repris quelques études mais dire
que tout cela je pense n'est pas sans
rapport avec le fait que j'ai eu envie
de faire de la politique
désormais président de saint quentin en
yvelines à 64 ans jean michel fourgous
souhaite réconcilier droite et gauche
pour notamment assurer le développement
économique de l'agglomération et en
faire une vitrine de l'innovation